mmm-hmm but the next door will be
[ __ ] bad
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show of hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by digital media mogul
Gary Vaynerchuk he's the CEO of
vaynermedia a New York Times bestselling
author four times over venture
capitalist TV show host a motivational
speaker but how does the man handle his
hot wings we'll find out today Gary Vee
welcome to the show thanks for having me
how are you with hot food I think I'm
solid amongst my small group of friends
I'm dominant but that's only about eight
people so we're about to put it into
context right now
[Music]
oh this is like on here already mm-hmm
this is the one all the way over here
mm-hmm
so this is gonna blow my face off yep
okay do you know how I eat chicken wings
how do you eat chicken wings literally
every single piece and like break the
bone and eat the marrow like I leave
nothing
I think that's easy to say I'm Valentina
Gary we'll see if you still have that
life philosophy when we get to Blair's
Megadeth sauce well I know that you're a
huge sports fan so much so in fact
you've described owning the New York
Jets as an ultimate life goal yes why
that dream specifically why is that the
top of the mountain for you so I was
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union I came here as a kid and at first
not speaking the language when I moved
to Edison New Jersey I went outside Erik
Godfrey and a couple other guys are
playing with that whole school nerf
football green and white and they kind
of accepted me in and they're like you
play football I'm like dah you know like
and I got in there and then right away I
watched the first Jets game in that 82
season and it became my thing
it was my break into American culture
your Americanized through the Jets I was
Americanized through the Jets and then
you know if that's a fairy tale that's
playing in your head I imagine that you
sometimes fantasize about the ways that
you'd put the garyvee fingerprints onto
the franchise yes what are some things
that you would do differently I would
draft a quarterback in the first round
of every draft until I found the guy I
think I would rip off people on trades I
just think I'm shrewd like that I would
talk [ __ ] back to my own New York jet
bands because any time they complain
about stuff I mean listen to me dick I'm
a bigger fan than you so that would be
funny and different
I fasted yesterday some hungry [ __ ]
so is delicious empty stomach hot sauce
situation some real chemistry going on
there huh so is someone who's been in
the room with tech Titans and these
investments and Facebook snapchat
Twitter and the like yep do you think
Silicon Valley gets a bad rap from the
media or their real cultural problems
that undermine the upside in your
opinion yeah I think there's some but
I'll be very honest with you there's a
lot on Madison Avenue too there's a lot
in all sorts of sectors I just think
that Silicon Valley is so cultural right
now
a bad rap of like it needs more
diversity everybody needs more diversity
and then you know I think that Mark
Zuckerberg probably has the most
disproportionate how much power he has
to what we know about him ratio in the
country okay as someone who's actually
spent time with the sucks what do people
get wrong about him I think this notion
of he's a tech nerd and he built it cuz
of a girl all that [ __ ] I just think
he's a genuinely good guy smartest [ __ ]
and disproportionately understands human
behavior
besides Jeff Bezos I think he's probably
the most understanding of consumer
behavior which makes him extremely
dangerous as an entrepreneur his
Facebook a force of good a force of evil
doesn't matter
Facebook is a mirror everybody's super
pumped about blaming other people for
their own [ __ ] technology's exposing who
you are not changing you Facebook's a
mirror
[Music]
it's funny I was a little bit worried
because the first one likes a little
spice here that's the first one but the
fact that Khalid bounced after this one
that's lame I'm in good shape stuff so I
know that you're a fan of hip-hop and
I've heard you say that you've listened
to Bone Thugs first of the month over
8,000 times in your life and you seem to
be especially drawn to this new breed of
superstars who made a wave on YouTube
and through the power of the internet
yeah besides raw talent what do you
think separates someone who has a little
bit of internet buzz and a mixtape on
soundcloud from someone who say at the
top of the industry like chance the
rapper if you [ __ ] Brian because you
love it so much
I believe work ethic is a huge variable
and this is why if you seems like you've
done your homework a boogie Kyle rust
there one song away your one song away
not every business is like that musics
incredible hip-hop especially like just
put out more stuff to give you more
chance as someone who spends time with
artists like a boogie kyle young pinch
who do you see as the next Forbes list
big power player in hip-hop that's a
good question so I think russ has a
ridiculous chip on his shoulder that may
be enough for him to pull it off like
he's just competitive and like [ __ ] you
I'm gonna show you and I'm like that and
I like that and I think that's a really
interesting insight ASAP Berg really is
creative and really understands culture
and really understands how to like hack
attention even though he's a little
further along is interesting to me from
afar I'm not gonna like anoint because I
don't know but I know that they have a
huge advantage because I do think
hip-hop is the disproportionate seed in
our culture and that a lot of these kids
have big opportunities especially if
they put in the work
I assume the amount of hot sauces that
are sent here like you like raise hot
sauce all your [ __ ] at home I mean I I'm
a little bit more into it I think when
I'm not shooting because I have other
food shows and stuff so when I'm off the
clock I'm really into like cereal and
juice maybe super light corn crops to me
are like the best frosted flakes pretty
unfuck with a bowl like in their
position
yes I go to Whole Foods now so I'm
always just ripping off their ripoff
versions some with the Panda puffs and
is that because it's a little bit
healthier it's just because there's a
Whole Foods halfway between my gym and
my apartment I know that you're a
connoisseur of wine and the wine
business and it set the foundation for
everything that you've built since I do
want to talk some wine to do it for the
viewers out there yes if you walk into a
wine shop 15 bucks Portugal Portugal is
the big steel in the market right now
you can get what I would call $40
equivalent in California France and
Italy for 15 and under call it 12 to 15
the difference between a $9.99 and a $13
is significant huge so don't be cheap
there that's not the place like if
you're at 10 cuz you know these are all
round numbers if you're at 10 like like
like just go up to 13 oh your own
private label mm-hmm respect
I love the Entrepreneurship I knew you'd
like that theory I'm excited you guys
sell this uh-huh let's order some I want
to support gangster entrepreneurship I
Curie's every current segment on our
show called explain that Graham we do a
deep dive and I guess Instagram and pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so I'll show you the picture and
then you can just tell me the bigger
story does that sound good
that is [ __ ] incredible that is that
needs to be shown itself you guys need
to think about that we need to bucket
that out mm-hmm why don't we think of
that do you rock that's very smart
you and the rock yes people were excited
about this one so I see the rocks follow
me so I DM em I'm like yo like I don't
know if this is your social media team
or you but cool like thanks for the love
they're not like an hour later like DMZ
he's like no but speed brother and I'm
like holy [ __ ] like get out I've gotten
owned a little bit like winners win man
winners win winners are on time winners
are humble winners grind winners never
get too caught up and who they are
winners look at everybody and say what's
up
winners win he [ __ ] wins he's gonna
win the whole [ __ ] thing this young
entrepreneurs yes Benny over here talk
to me about Benjamin kicks oh this is me
like just so everybody knows like if I
was born in a different genre you'd be
Benjamin I'd be selling so many [ __ ]
sneak I'd be destroying Benjamin Kings
if I was going through the system right
now zero point zero chance that I would
have graduated high school zero uh and
you know it's funny I was about to say
easy didn't become a straight douchebag
or a winner I don't think he will become
a straight douchebag I think he's been
trying to be thoughtful he's asking the
right questions it's hard right right
it's hard to be around all that money
and all those girls and all these real
celebrities he's so young I don't know
what would have happened to me I got put
on that early so I root for him and I
stay close to him cuz I want him to win
you'll put up these shorts all the time
on Instagram and sometimes you'll take
semi unpopular positions like when you
dre old against Friday's your example
yeah at its basic form if you genuinely
celebrate Friday you need to rethink
your entire [ __ ] game to live your
life where you love Friday night
Saturday and Sunday and despise Monday
through Thursday or Friday morning is
devastating to me because you're wasting
too much of your life and I'm trying to
put pressure on the conversation to say
if you love Friday that much then you
need to really look at Monday through
Thursday and see if you can do something
about it please do not waste the next 5
10 15 20 30 years of your life and
allocate 30 40 50 60 percent of your
time to something that you hear to end
each and every week
I like it it's got a little bit of a
sweetness undertone mm-hmm so one of my
favorite things about you is your
willingness to dole out free advice so
right now I just need a little Gary Vee
brand consulting so let me set the table
for you here
all right we have about 2 million
YouTube subscribers decent little wave
big reddit support audience yes and then
on top of that we have a to such an
incredible part of our culture it's a
really it's a great part of the internet
yeah I very grateful we're very
fortunate to have any of that because to
be real with you Gary we have no idea
what the [ __ ] we're doing around here
yes I understand so if we handed you the
reins it would be much bigger what's the
top line game plan for how one's so what
I do well sure is I reverse engineer
okay I start at what we need to have
happen and I go backwards until I get
there like a Plinko you know the [ __ ]
plane goes but right right right
that's how I think so go ahead so I'd
say this I'm obsessed with the show and
it kind of started as a goof and then
when you see it's snowball you just
become obsessed that's right with the
growth that's right and then I think
also what drives me is sort of this chip
on my shoulder thing where I see other
things that are bigger and more popular
some almost motivate now you take a
chance better because like everybody
thinks their kid is cute but a bunch of
them are ugly yeah it's probably at some
level like I own a house and sit on the
market and I overprice it because I'm
obsessed yes in love with this do you
want growth right now right is there an
audio version of this show no it's just
the straight I'm so [ __ ] pissed right
now
like this needs to be a podcast you
literally need to transcribe this entire
thing right now dom get busy I'm sure
you're not writing a blog post or a
medium article or LinkedIn post or
something on reddit that is a recap six
paragraphs of this interview either
right we just upload and leave right but
it's about creating the other forms of
media podcast yesterday podcast
yesterday on the popularity this you're
gonna be a top 300 podcast in two
seconds that's gonna create a viral loop
then people gonna watch the video you
got to be in every format that's a
hundred percent now there
thing you need to do this live at
cultural events we're there thank God
[ __ ] but like everything else too got it
Dom oh we were taking notes yes this is
cranking it up a little bit mm-hmm
mm-hmm
but I'm super unfazed well get you Gary
I have the time proud of myself right
now
because what I don't think most people
understand is how much life is mental
I'm a big believer in that and it hot
ones is very mental I think so basically
decided that I will not lose to the
sauces I mean I'm a little scared cuz
that was pretty hot there's three more
to go so as we just discussed you're
very content is king you have a
videographer today it seems like almost
everything you do is being documented
what are the things that don't make it
to the internet 90% of my life nothing
about my family and kids and private
life and 80% of my business world I
can't share because I'm in meetings with
Chase and Budweiser and I'm firing
people hiring people or they're talking
[ __ ] about people almost everything do
you think that it's strange at all that
everything is being captured and
recorded or is this the new normal is in
new normal I think it's strange for
people that are not capturing like my
great-great-great-great grandson
Jeremiah is watching this right now hey
Jeremiah like you know it's like that's
[ __ ] amazing I'm a little worried
about this one this one looks
let's go [ __ ] death you know like hey
just keeps looking at me like
[Music]
you know it's interesting I'm very
observant watching the faces of the
camera people because they have insights
they've seen this dance before so I went
into that pretty confident and then dude
with the wine shirt I'm like [ __ ] I'm
walking into a buzzsaw slow but I feel
okay so far so the spiciest [ __ ] but I'm
too mentally strong to waver so you seem
to relish turning these viral sensations
into viable floating stars so what I
want to do is have a little bit of a
mock draft what we've done is pulled
some of the most influential people in
the space we've bucketed them out so
that's some of them are $5 some of them
are $4 3 2 1 I'm gonna give you 15 bucks
to build the roster does that sound good
yeah this is interesting by the way the
next two [ __ ] wings would be real
trouble [ __ ] fire I'm so pissed okay
how much do I have to spend you have
fifteen dollars to spend our friends
over at everyday struggle did this with
rappers this time around we're doing it
with viral sensation so the most
firepower
is what you're looking for look this is
tough $15 right 15 bucks
I love Cameron Dallas 14 we have a
dollar I really need 16 I woulda been
set okay it looks like then this is
interesting you've pulled one person
from each category then of $1 a $2 $3 $4
$5 which is interesting to me can you
talk your choices out for me in West
damn Daniel is $1 I still think there's
a lot of legs there I feel like it's out
nobody gives a [ __ ] anymore right but I
think as soon as I just said the M
Daniel everybody had a reaction which
means there's still something there and
that's super important a backpack kid
mm-hmm three bucks I just met with him
recently I think he's got an interesting
chip which I you know he's like I know
two bucks it just seemed like a good
deal I'm also into backpack culture I
think it's just starting I don't think
this goes away so quickly
I think Cameron Dallas really knows what
the [ __ ] he's doing he could have easily
been in the four and five dollar
category he's an entrepreneur and a
model and a big audience because he's
the most obvious of this bunch that
could have been five and he's smart he's
not just a pretty face I think he's
gonna be around $4 Jake Paul I struggled
this one cuz cardi B is amazing King
badge I think is super talented cuz I
want to get bash as well but that made
it 16 that's what I get about that but
Jake I think is going through an
interesting moment right now he's taking
some heat it's been a little rogue
little like MTV jackass kind of stuff
and 11 years we'll be watching this
he'll be in the world doing something
another child star right now Kylie
Jenner is top 10 most culturally
impactful people and I noticed that it
was the first name that you circled Gary
that was a great observation by you and
that's because she's worth 10 but the
next soon we [ __ ] bad
[ __ ]
[Music]
tap it ahead up decent shape it's
kicking in late god damn it you need
alright I'll take my El so you seem to
have a really unique insight on the way
that the tides are changing particularly
in media and it seems to me so odd
because these bedroom vlogs and all
these do-it-yourself videos with
basically zero budget seem to be
attracting eyeballs in a way that big TV
shows with big budgets aren't anymore
cuz this is the television and that's
the radio it's not odd it's just that
people aren't accepting what the [ __ ] is
actually happening I don't feel like the
industry is totally caught up like I
think that there are a lot of marketers
and sales people that still are caught
in like 2010 or so they're either
financially restricted meaning it's in
their financial interest to not accept
the new world normally or be they suck
everyone's so risk-averse because they
have these like corner office jobs or
whatever those executives and then they
always just do some sort of like
cost-benefit analysis that isn't about
growing or making it bigger or making it
the best thing in the world but just
about keeping their jobs or some [ __ ]
that's exactly right
it's pure defense when or how do you see
the tide changing like in other words I
feel like this show has more eyeballs on
it than most TV shows that like what
point do you think I don't have to show
explain that Graham off my laptop
anymore when [ __ ] start going at a
business
you know when Toys R Us goes out of
business the toy manufacturers are like
wait a minute I just gotta wait for the
media apocalypse and then it's good
times for Shawn I'm correct a hundred
thousand percent when people are like
jumping out of windows and the world's
collapse you're like yeah alright Gary
Vee
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
like it's a little extra on the last
wing okay you don't have to if you don't
want to but I'm not gonna stop Gary Vee
but believable garyvee do I have the
cleanest bones in the history of the
show yes yes bonus bones [ __ ]
alright Gary now that you have ten wings
yes the last dab coursing through your
veins it's time to hit the people with
some truth okay you know you're a man
who's all about the small-scale hustle
of flipping a buck lemonade stand [ __ ] I
wonder from your perspective yes what do
you think is the difference between a
hustler someone who actually grabs the
bull by the horns and then all these
phonies who talk about it entitlement we
think they deserve it without it putting
in the work nobody owes you [ __ ]
everybody wants a complain nobody's
listening the plates you would be
stunned how many of the winners lack
that entitlement some people have it it
happens some people get fancy and they
feel the stars that you know they're not
around anymore they don't [ __ ] matter
because they sold the [ __ ] out and they
thought they were something I wake up
every morning thinking that everything
I've done is what I've done
I don't deserve [ __ ] today may be the
day it all falls apart I'm only as good
as my last at-bat
I'm not [ __ ] I think those are people
that are winning we're just a bunch of
animals on this space rock trying to
figure it all out
and Gary you have more insight than most
I think whole room not a dry eye in the
house and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you Gary
thank you this camera this camera or
this camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life honestly I
know that this is the plug time I
actually have nothing to plug here's
what I want I want you to [ __ ]
suffocate your [ __ ] excuses and go
do something
forget about what I'm doing go do
something it's time
[Music]
on a very serious note what do you think
like rank me all-time on this show
top three who are the other two uh TJ
Miller I really liked okay and I don't
know there's no top to top to [ __ ] TJ
hey what's going on hot ones fans a
quick heads up the second annual complex
con is coming to Long Beach California
November 4th and 5th and you know first
we feast and hot ones are gonna be in
the building there's gonna be a live hot
ones taping we're gonna be doing a panel
with my buddies Andy Milonakis and Matty
Matheson the last dab will be for sale
it's a whole thing
total circus hope to see you there